[موسيقى]
في تطورات الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
ذكرت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه ان اعنف
المعارك تدور حاليا عند مدينه بخموت شمال
مقاطعه دونتس في شرق اوكرانيا واضافه ان
15 قريه في محيط مدينه
تعرضت لقصف روسيا شديد وافاد مراسل
الجزيره عن تعرض منطقه خار كيف لقصف
صاروخيا فجر اليوم حيث سمع انفجاران في
محيط المدينه عقب اطلاقه صفارات الانذار
من جانبه اكد رئيس الاداره العسكريه
الاوكرانيه اوليج
فان القوات الروسيه قصفت اكثر من 20 بلده
ومدينه في مقاطعه خلال ساعه الاربعاء
والعشرين الماضيه جهه اخرى افاد حاكم
مدينه سيفا ستوبل ميخائيل روزفو جيف ان
الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه في شبه جزيره
القرم تمكنت من اسقاط مسيرتين اوكرانيتين
فوق البحر وتواصل التصدي لاي هجوم في
وتواصل التصديا لاي جمل في المنطقه